[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
hello and welcome to Sophie Ridge on
Sunday
it's five days since Rishi sunak walked
into Downing Street apologizing for
mistakes made promising a government of
integrity and accountability the
conservatives do seem to have stabilized
in the polls if they're making some
progress on the economy but the ongoing
row over sweller braverman's return to
the home office threatens to overshadow
the Shadow His pledge and there's an
extraordinary story of Liz Trotter's
phone being hacked by Russia raising
fresh concerns over National Security
all that is a fresh election loomed in
Northern Ireland with little sign it
could break the deadlock at show ahead
with our guests this morning
one of the more eye-catching
appointments in Michigan's cabinet was
the return of Michael Gove to his old
apartment will hear from the leveling up
secretary in just a moment
but it was the reappointment of soilla
Braverman that caused the most
controversy the rail rumbling on still
we'll be talking to the shadow Home
Secretary Yvette Cooper plus we've got
two big exclusives from Northern Ireland
on the program this morning the Northern
Ireland secretary says he will call
elections there after six months of
gridlock I'll talk exclusively to
Michelle O'Neill The Voice the vice
president of shin Fein first Minister
elect of the stormwatch assembly we'll
also have an exclusive interview with
the dep leader Sir Jeffrey Donaldson on
the program
meanwhile the war in Ukraine continues
with both sides digging in ahead of what
could be a particularly Grim winter
we'll talk to the Ukrainian MP in a
substance live from Kiev plus with
leveling up back on the agenda we'll
talk to Susan Hinchcliffe the leader of
the council in Bradford
[Music]
yeah
good morning well could leveling up be
back under Rishi sunak the new prime
minister made a point of emphasizing it
as he entered Downing Street but we know
there are in the words of the chancellor
eye-wateringly difficult decisions on
spending cuts ahead so how do you level
up if there's no money and what's really
been achieved in three years since the
big Promises of the 2019 election well
I've been speaking to Michael Gove who
is now back for his second stint as
leveling up secretary
you've written in the salon Sunday today
to say the conservative party owes the
public an apology for installing list
trust's leader so would you like to
apologize yes I think we made a mistake
we took the wrong turn uh the mini
budget as I think everyone now
recognizes contained a a number of false
steps I think it was wrong to cut taxes
for the wealthiest and it was also wrong
to proceed with tax cuts without saying
how they were going to be paid for
um and to be fair Jeremy Hunters
Chancellor as soon as he was installed
made clear that those mistakes would
have to be addressed and Rishi sunak as
prime minister of course has been
Vindicated to some of the judgments that
he made during the course of the summer
during the course of the leadership
election have been shown to be correct
and Rishi now along with Jeremy and the
rest of us in government have some
difficult decisions to take but what we
must do is be honest with the British
people in order to regain trust
um talking about regetting trust is the
store in the mail on Sunday today that
Liz truss's phone and was hacked by the
Kremlin an astonishing story is it true
well I don't know the details of it and
I do know that the government takes
cyber security incredibly serious you
know if it's true or not I I think you
might not know that I I know I don't
know the full details
um and so again I I the mail on Sunday
is a trusted newspaper
um but I don't know the full details of
what security breach if any took place
what I do know is that the government
has very robust protocols in place in
order to make sure that uh individuals
are protected but also the government
security and National Security are
protected as well according to the story
they say that um the Kremlin gained
access to confidential exchanges
including about armed shipments to
Ukraine personal exchanges with a Chance
Le quasi quattang and it's also reported
that there was effectively a cover-up
you know Boris Johnson and Simon case
ahead of the Civil Service agreeing to a
news blackout I mean should list trusts
have come clean if this was true well
again I'm sure that Liz both as foreign
secretary and as Prime Minister will
have followed the advice that she was
given by the intelligence and security
communities and I think all of us have
to be sensitive particularly those of us
in government to the fact that the more
that we talk in detail about these
things the more that we risk giving
information to people who wish this
country and its citizens harm so uh I'm
sure that the right protocols were
followed I'm sure that more information
as appropriate will be released I guess
some people listening might be
questioning you know if this is you know
government committed to National
Security given that suela Braverman you
know resigned after emailing these
confidential papers from a personal
email account to someone outside a
government and also copying in the wrong
person as well a week later she was back
you know you take a week off work if
you've got the flu not if you've
committed a security breach was she seem
like I've appointed her yes we do take
security issues incredibly seriously
that's why again I have to be cautious
in responding to the point that you
understandably made about uh Liz's phone
and it's because we take them seriously
that we have uh strict protocols in
place that govern how information should
be shared and with whom it should be
shared Sue Ella is a first-rate front
rank politician she acknowledged that a
mistake had been made she is working
hard in order to ensure that our borders
can be made more secure and that
policing is more effective and she's a
valued member of the cabinet and someone
whom I admire and like you said that
she's an effective Frontline politician
but there are reports in the Sunday
Times today that she ignored legal
advice that the government was illegally
detaining thousands of Asylum Seekers at
the manston processing center in Kent
you know this is somewhere where people
are only space to save for 24 hours the
support of families being there for four
weeks is that acceptable no the
situation in manston is not what it
should be but again it's important to
stress that the Home Secretary did not
ignore or dismiss legal advice the Home
Secretary was balancing a number of
different uh competing imperatives it's
absolutely vital of course that we
process people as quickly as possible
it's also important that we keep them in
conditions which are Humane but it's
like Humane now yes but it is also the
case that we're facing an unprecedented
number of people arriving here who are
smuggled into this country by criminal
gangs and the Home Secretary is focused
both on making sure that we can break
that criminal Network and also that we
can find appropriate accommodation for
people as quickly as possible it's not
appropriate is it a manston for families
to stay for four weeks there you
acknowledge that well we want people to
be inappropriate accommodation as
quickly as quickly as possible well the
situation is not perfect everyone
acknowledges that we have more than 2
000 people there at the moment but again
these are people who haven't come to
this country seeking Asylum when they're
in manston their Claims can be processed
more quickly and more efficiently than
was the case in the past and in manston
there are medical personnel
um others who are trained in
safeguarding in order to make sure that
people are treated in a Humane and
civilized manner again uh when it comes
to finding appropriate accommodation
with them to move on to hotel or other
accommodation then that is costing a
taxpayer's significance on it's
important that we get that right and one
of the things that Sue Ella was
absolutely determined to do was to make
sure that we balance all of the
competing concerns
um I want to talk to you about leveling
up yes in 2019 you won an election on a
Manifesto that pledged to level up now
you've had three years to make progress
on that but the per person spending gap
between North and London doubled between
2019 and 2021 that's according to the
ippr Bloomberg did a big data study
about leveling up in June and it found
most places are going backwards 21
Center constituencies in the north west
leveling up 31 in the Northeast only
four percent in Yorkshire nine percent
in the southwest none at all across the
whole of the Midlands I mean why do you
think you're going to make a bigger
success with this time than last time
well the statistics that you've um uh
brought out are uh all powerful evidence
of why it's more important than ever but
we level up of course the situation has
become more difficult partly as a result
of covert partly as a result of
inflation but we won't succeed as a
country unless we make sure that those
parts of the United Kingdom that have
been less productive uh the north
Midlands the South West are made more
productive and that requires yes
investment but it also requires much
more than that it requires giving local
leaders the power to make a difference
do you acknowledge that you haven't done
enough since that big promise in 2019
when people many of them voted for you
for the first time on that promise we've
made progress but it's not enough you're
absolutely right so we can look at
specific parts of the United Kingdom
where uh progress has been made if we
look for example at T side and the
example of Ben hatch on the mayor there
um in the time that he's been elected
we've supported him to invest in the
local economy uh whether that's T side
airport or the new teas work site
um which uh used to be the site of a
steel works now the site of one of the
biggest investments in Renewables
um in the country that is a change that
is bringing high value jobs to t-site
and it's a change that's being driven by
a conservative mayor in partnership with
the conservative government our
investment zones still happening there
were a big list for us push I'm
reviewing them so potentially not we we
need to make sure that any change that
we make is one which of course helps to
support economic growth and good jobs
for people in need but also one of the
uh concerns raised about investment
zones was the impact act on the
environment I've been very clear and
that prime minister has been very clear
that under no circumstances will we
weaken Environmental Protections so uh I
I will be looking with the chancellor of
the exchequer with the environment
secretary and with the prime minister at
the proposals that were drawn up when
Liz was prime minister and anything that
might in any way undermine Environmental
Protections is out
um on the environment and you of course
have campaigned on green issues for many
years now but today Alex Sharma the
government's climate chains are has said
that Russia sunax should go to clock 27
that's the climate change at Summit that
he says he's too busy with the Autumn
statement to attend he's also said that
the conservatives will be punished at
the election if you can row back from
the environmental focus is he right well
I think first of all Alex on an amazing
job as cop president secondly our
commitment to the environment is our
absolute and critical
um thirdly when it comes to attendance
at cop I know that across government we
want to feel the strongest possible team
at cult but there are strong pressures
on the prime minister's diary and on the
pressures of others ultimately I think
when it comes to matters environmental
we'll be judged on what we deliver
um where the fastest decarbonizing
economy in the G7 there is much more to
do and we are doing it so moving towards
electric vehicles making sure that we
invest in Renewables and also critically
making sure that we help nature to
recover both in the territory of the
United Kingdom but also in the oceans
for which we're responsible
attending the cop Summit why doesn't
King Charles go well again I think uh I
I you'll entirely understand um I don't
want to get drawn into details about
what members of the royal family will do
where they should be where they should
go
um but it was clear advice from the
government wasn't it well again I don't
want to be if you forgive me I will
avoid answering that question thank you
for being upfront about it I will be
upfront in avoiding answering that
question because I I don't want to be
drawn into something you think you
should go no no no no no I don't want to
be drawn into matters relating to uh
where the king is where he should go on
so and I just for me is it um the
particular approach I take towards these
issues is that one shouldn't do that but
we will be Fielding the strongest
possible team at Cobb uh now I just want
to play a video that might be familiar
to well I'm sure it's affirmative to you
but potentially to our viewers as well
it's our hostings over the summer where
Rishi sunak was filmed talking about
taking money away from deprived in the
city areas let's just have a little
watch
I mean it's just not changing the
funding formulas to make sure that areas
like this are getting the funding that
they deserve because we inherited a
bunch of formulas from the labor party
that shoved all the funding into
deprived urban areas uh then they you
know that needed to be undone I started
the work of undoing that
but he's talking there about undoing the
work of as he calls it shoving funding
into deprived area urban areas and I
know that you'll say look there is Rule
of poverty too I agree with you on that
but you know he's not talking about you
know some parts of Cornwall or
Lincolnshire where there is rural
deprivation he was talking Tunbridge
Wells that's 273 out of 317 in the index
of deprivation is that someone serious
about leveling up yes because he was
responding directly to a question from
someone from uh than it uh you'll be
aware that that part of Northeast Kent
is one of the most deprived parts of the
southeast that communities in Margate
and Ramsgate even though there's been
welcome investment there recently do
face deprivation poor housing there are
a number of social ills there he was
directly addressing that point and the
primers was made clear of course there
was deprivation in our big cities that
we needed to address but there is also
Rural and Coastal deprivation which does
need to be addressed as well and
leveling up of course needs to be
focused on the North and the Midlands
but somewhere like thanet is definitely
an area that requires government
attention uh in order to improve the
outcomes for people there okay uh now
you did an interview with the financial
times uh in October this is before of
course you had your big comeback if you
like to the cabinet yes you said this
about brexit I was quite interested in
this you said I asked myself all the
time was it the right thing to do I
still think that it was right but that
doesn't mean that a choice as momentous
as this doesn't require you from time to
time to think what are the downsides has
it turned out in the way you might have
imagined what lessons can you learn and
I'm I'm actually very interested to know
your answer to some of the questions you
posed you know what are the downsides do
you think well I I think it's important
to look at a big question like brexit
and to recognize that you can't make a
snap judgment a few years later and say
definitively that everything as a result
of uh leaving the European Union has
gone precisely in a perfect way I think
on balance brexit has been a significant
success for this country but I do
acknowledge that there have been
frictions and my friend Steve Baker for
example acknowledged that as we resolve
the situation in Northern Ireland but
some of the things that being said and
done haven't necessarily been perfectly
pitched I think that is an example of
something that we need to address but
overall I think we wouldn't have had the
vaccine rollout that was so successful
if we'd been within the European Union
and in an area for which I was
previously responsible in the
environment we wouldn't have a better
method of supporting Farmers that
strengthens the environment as well as
enhancing food production if we were in
the common agricultural policy and in my
own area there are opportunities now
that the prime minister is exploring to
change the way in which some of the big
funds the Pension funds invest which
will mean that more money can go into
leveling up areas those are three big
benefits of brexit you talk about the
challenges with Northern Ireland and I
think many people would agree that it's
perhaps the biggest challenge of brexit
we'll be talking about that later on the
program as well Jeffrey Donaldson of the
dep telling Sky News another election
won't break the deadlock and the UK
actually needs to focus on negotiations
with the EU over the brexit protocol is
right well we do need to focus on
negotiations
um and so Jeffrey is a friend and I
think that I would say to him and to all
the parties in Northern Ireland that
were in a strong position to deliver for
the people of Northern Ireland if all
the parties get back into the executive
that is what the Northern Ireland
secretary and the Prime Minister have
consistently said we also needed to
negotiate with the European Union in
order to find a way through and again to
be fair uh figures from Tony Blair to
those in the Irish government and indeed
those in the EU have acknowledged that
the protocol isn't working in its
current form and it needs to be fixed
was um going back to kind of your sort
of brexit thoughts was the situation in
Northern Ireland more difficult than you
expected well I certainly uh thought
that there would be uh challenges I
think one of the the issues here and I
don't want to sort of uh you know put
the blame on anyone particularly but I
do think
um in retrospect the way in which the
European Union insisted on the protocol
as a means of resolving the issues in
Northern Ireland
um the the way in which they did so was
overly legalistic
um and it did and didn't take account of
the reality signed up to the protocol
and Boris Johnson said it was a great
deal though well again the protocol was
supposed to be a sort of living
instrument
um I sat on a committee that was
explicitly designed to make sure that
the protocol worked effectively and one
of the things that I said to people in
the EU is you are trying to apply the
protocol in a way which will mean that
it will not work effectively
um and there has I mean I'm I'm not
claiming any great sort of insight
um but the the arguments that I was
putting and that Boris was putting to
the EU at the time have been Vindicated
okay now
um just a couple of things to finish
um you've prepped Rishi sunic for his
first uh prime minister's question to
involved in that and you also of course
were involved in the PM's Keys
preparation for Boris Johnson David
Cameron how do they all compare I'm
fascinated well um obviously um the
public will make the Judgment there I
think that Rishi did brilliantly in his
first preparation yes everyone has
different ways don't know preparing for
food I was wondering if you know we know
that Rishi next uh uh quite partial to a
can of Coke did you have any particular
you know ways of preparing well um uh
the the again
um that morning we had cabinet and then
we discussed some of the questions that
might come up at Prime Minister's
question time um Rishi is as you would
expect he's familiarly well briefed but
wasn't an issue that was likely to come
up uh which he didn't you know have the
full background on
um and also look this was one of the
first occasions on which the the public
was seeing him as prime minister uh the
thing that struck me is that he was um
you know cool and unflappable beforehand
um I'm sure like football players
um every prime minister will have a
ritual immediately beforehand I knew
that David Cameron used to have a cup of
tea with three or four sugars in just to
give him that extra burst
um and um I know that when Boris was a
prime minister uh he liked to have uh
one of the the team in number 10 play
kyostarma um and so there were two
particular uh aides who at different
times played kirst armor um Richie likes
to look at it issue by issue by issue in
a very methodical way does someone play
Kirsten with ferocious Enoch as well
um there is one incredibly bright person
who ran through the questions that kirst
armor might um uh might run
um I will spare the blushes of that
person uh simply to say that she's one
of the smartest people I've ever worked
with okay uh very interesting to know
that you've had a bit of a comeback as
well haven't you were you expecting uh
to be back in cabinet no does this mean
we're going to be seeing a bit less of
you in the nightclubs yes okay thank you
very much indeed thanks anyway thank you
leveling up secretary now we're talking
an awful lot about security issues uh in
that interview and labor says it will
try to use parliamentary tactics to
force the government to disclose any
security assessments of the home
secretaries Sue Ella Braverman before
she was reappointed by the Prime
Minister now that of course was just six
days after she resigned for breaking the
ministerial code well we can talk now to
labor Shadow Home Secretary Yvette
Cooper who joins us now uh live
um I just before we get to braveman I'm
interested in the story extraordinary
story on the front page of the mail
about Liz truss's phone reportedly being
compromised by Michael Gove said he
wasn't across the details in the
interview uh earlier but but what is
your response to these allegations
well clearly these are very serious
allegations it raises issues around
cyber security it's why cyber security
has to be taken so seriously by everyone
across government at the role of hostile
States but also the allegations about
whether a cabinet minister has been
using a personal phone or serious
government business and serious
questions about why this information or
this story has been leaked or briefed
right now and all of these I think just
go to the part that's raising questions
about the way in which the government is
not taking seriously enough National
Security and of course the serious
problem is the person who ought to be
providing reassurance that the
government has a grip the person who
ought to be doing interviews this
morning about all of this is the Home
Secretary Suella bravaman and she can't
do that because she's still unable to
answer those serious questions about her
own security breaches and lapses and
that's why I think this is a problem
really for Rishi doing that not simply
the story this morning about Liz Trust
you say about questions about why it was
leaked now what do you mean by that
well there's just a question about why
this story which obviously has
implications for National Security
itself is now being briefed or been
leaked today as well so as well as the
actual events that have taken place I
think it's really it's important that I
really hope that this hasn't been leaked
for example to try and distract from
some of the other things that are
happening because obviously I think
actually it does the opposite and just
raises wider concerns about the way in
which the government is not taking
seriously enough these issues around
National Security
that you of course have been very strong
in calling for more information about
what happened with Zoella rather than
she resigned of course after emailing at
those papers from a personal email
account what exactly are you calling for
excuse me just putting umbrella up um
Sophie is getting quite wet here thanks
um so we think that we have to have we
have to have uh proper answers about
whether or not this was the first
security breach from Sue Ella bravaman
we think that the papers and the
warnings that were provided by the
cabinet office and by the cabinet
secretary to the Prime Minister should
be sent to the intelligence and security
committee so far we have been asking
repeatedly whether the Home Secretary
has used her personal phone to send
other government documents there's also
questions about whether she was
investigated for other security leaks
including around a case involving
security service and around a case
involving sensitive legal advice around
Northern Ireland now this is just
irresponsible you can't have a Home
Secretary who is not trusted by the
security service who is not trusted with
important government information and it
really shows the huge error of judgment
that Rishi sunak has made in
reappointing someone just six days after
she broke the ministerial code over
security lapses reappointing her to this
immensely serious position National
Security is too important for this kind
of chaos confusion and really
irresponsible decision making another
reports in the Sunday Times that swella
Braverman ignored the legal advice that
the government was illegally detaining
thousands of Asylum Seekers at manston a
processing center in Kent Michael Gove
acknowledged two hours on the program
earlier that it's not good enough that
more needs to be done
what exactly should happen to those
families do you think and how much would
it cost given the you know premium that
labor is putting on making sure
everything that you're announcing is
fully costed
there is an immediate action that the
Home Secretary needs to take to make
sure that the home office is compliant
with the law to make sure that you don't
have the kind of shopping conditions
that the inspector has described with an
Afghan family a number Mark in a marquee
for 32 days and overcrowding that
appears to have led to a diphtheria
outbreak in the UK as a result of the
home office not responding properly but
look there is a wider issue here that
this is a result of the collapse in
Asylum decision making they're only
taking half the number of Designing
decisions that they were taking five or
six years ago that has led to a huge
backlog and of course a failure to have
a proper deal and agreement in place
with France or to crack down on the
criminal gangs so we're not preventing a
lot of these dangerous Boat Crossings in
the first place and really the
irresponsible issue is that government
is still pursuing spending 140 million
pounds now on a Rwanda deal that the
Home Secretary herself has admitted is
failing that money it should be cut and
put into cracking down on the criminal
gangs instead and that would help
address some of these problems
it's difficult though isn't it because I
know as you will acknowledge you know
there are record numbers of small boats
crossing the channel everyone is
grappling to try and find a way out of
this and you know people talked about
cracking down on the criminal gangs
before it's not that easy though is it
if it was that easy everyone would just
click their fingers and do it
nothing is easy in this but there hasn't
been a serious strategy to to tackle the
criminal gangs we've seen a huge
proliferation they've effectively
created a multi-million pound criminal
industry on the channel over the last
few years this has increased very
dramatically just over the last few
years
and British authorities to deal with it
so I think what you need we've proposed
a new selling an elite unit as part of
the National Crime agency with hundreds
of specialist offices to work with
europol with the French authorities to
actually crack down on those criminal
gangs and to get some prosecutions we've
seen in other areas of serious organized
crime when there have been substantial
prosecutions it has had an impact on the
whole network at the moment for many of
these criminal gangs they see this as a
cost-free crime because the costs and
the risks are in people's lives being
put at risk in the channel and that is
what is so dangerous and that's where
they should be cracking down the
government instead has spent another 20
million pounds just in the last three
months on the Rwanda deal which isn't
actually in danger of increasing
trafficking and increasing that criminal
gang activity that's been the evidence
from other countries so that's on top of
the 120 million pounds they've already
spent so I think that they are focusing
on headlines rather than the hard work
that's actually needed to tackle this
problem uh just finally because you are
I can see battling with the rain which
we do appreciate of course and I want to
start this question by acknowledging
that labor is still very very clearly
ahead in the polls but according to
opinion there are some issues the
government has regained a lead over with
four point lead on labor on the economy
a seven point lead on defense a
five-point lead on dealing with
terrorism do you think Rishi sunak is
more formidable opposition than Liz
Travis
you know I think he is part of 12 Years
of conservative government that has
caused deep damage to this country we
thought obviously the huge Damage Done
by the mini budgets the the chaotic huge
unfunded Cuts in taxes for the richest
people in the country that has done
permanent damage and people are now
paying higher mortgages as a result of
what's happened but the one thing I did
agree with Liz truss on is when she
described the 12 years of failed growth
under the conservatives they've had one
sort of growth experiment after another
that has not worked because they still
ultimately see this as a sort of
trickle-down approach which is really
damaging labor set out an alternative
plan you've heard from Kia stammer from
Rachel Reeves the series green
Prosperity plan a way to grow the
economy that I know you've had the
Tesco's chair on to talking about and
the importance of benefits that that has
for the country and for growing the
economy as well
uh thank you very much indeed event
Cooper I think we might need a new
Umbrella by the way
and now I think I might no
good to have you on the program today
uh Yvette Cooper there battling with uh
the rain and now let's turn to Northern
Ireland uh shall we the Secretary of
State Chris Heaton Harris plans to call
a new election after the deadline for
power sharing passed without agreement
dup leader Sir Jeffrey Donaldson says
another Assembly Election will not break
the deadlock and restore devold
government at Stormwind Mr Jeffrey says
there's been three prime ministers since
the last Auburn election and Chaos at
times in Westminster so he wants the
government to focus on negotiations with
the EU over the brexit protocol instead
of calling an election he's been
speaking to our senior Ireland
correspondent David Blevins exclusively
for this program
so Jeffrey Donaldson the dup won't
restore power sharing and the UK
government doesn't seem to know if it
wants an election in Northern Ireland or
not surely the people of Northern
Ireland deserve better governance than
this well indeed we want to see storm
restored as soon as possible and I say I
don't think an election takes us closer
to a solution so why not use the next
few weeks to double down on getting
either a negotiated solution with the
European Union or bringing forward the
legislation in Parliament that will
resolve the issues around the North
Island protocol but given that we're now
six months past the Assembly Election
there is no devolved government is the
Northern Ireland secretary not
legislatively obliged to call an
election well let's look what has
happened in those six months since the
Assembly Election we've had three prime
ministers Westminster at times has been
in chaos there's been little focus on
getting a solution to the protocol the
talks with the EU only started again a
couple of weeks ago and even then only
at attack critical level not at a
political level how is it easier to
resolve the problems around the protocol
outside of the power sharing government
rather than inside working together to
find a solution well of course David we
tried that for over two years we tried
to get a solution on the protocol and we
worked with the other parties we pressed
the government to take action and the EU
simply said no there will be no
renegotiation of the protocol and it
reached a point where our ministers in
Stormwind were required to impose
measures on the people of Northern
Ireland as a result of the protocol that
every day every single day was harming
our economy our businesses driving up
the cost of living for households
um you know 25 tariffs on steel products
coming from Birmingham to Belfast that
is ridiculous you say the EU says no the
dup says no to power sharing says no to
the protocol said no to Theresa May's
backstop option are you at the point
where the dep regrets saying yes to
brexit in the first place well we say
yes to power sharing but it has to be on
the basis of mutual respect it has to be
on the basis of adhering to the
principles of the Belfast or Good Friday
agreement and at the heart of that
agreement is that Northern Ireland is
part of the United Kingdom that was even
accepted by the Irish government who
changed their constitution to recognize
Northern Ireland as part of the UK the
protocol has cut across now we never
supported that the protocol we made
clear it would harm Northern Ireland it
would create instability and so it has
and I welcome the commitment now of the
EU to negotiate a new solution I welcome
the fact that the EU is now at the
negotiating table why is that David it's
because of the pressure we have put on
it's because of the steps the dup has
taken that finally we're getting a
negotiation a proper negotiation on
finding a solution to this problem the
that's what I've asked for and now we
need to see that solution coming forward
and frankly the sooner the better is
Rishi sunak the dup's worst nightmare
because he clearly doesn't want to trade
war with the EU and therefore isn't
going to tear up the protocol well look
I don't want a tree at war with the EU I
want to trade with the EU but I
fundamentally want the ability to trade
within my own country and that is what
the protocol denies us and look whoever
is the prime minister in Westminster I
have to work with them I have to work
with the government and I will I am
absolutely committed every single day to
working to find this solution and I will
work with risi sunak to get that
solution and all I ask of the government
is that the objectives that they have
outlined in the Northern Ireland
protocol bill which is currently before
parliament are the objectives that they
pursue in the negotiations Liz truss
gave us that commitment Rishi sunak has
also stated that he wants to achieve the
same objectives so let's get on with
that let's get this solution let's see
the negotiations and the tempo of those
negotiations increased so that we get to
an outcome that Universe can support
the refusal to restore power sharing is
it really about the protocol or is it
about the fact that Shin fein's Michelle
O'Neill is on course to become the first
nationalist first Minister look my party
is the Democratic unionist party that
means first of all we accept the outcome
of the election but let's not forget
David I withdrew my ministers from the
executive or the first Minister back in
February well before the election I
signaled way back in September last year
the the actions that we would take if a
solution was not found on the protocol
so this is not to do with who is the
first or Deputy first Minister this is
about the second part of what my party
stands for the Union
it is about unionists feeling that they
are they have been made second-class
citizens as a result of a protocol that
diminishes and undermines our place in
the United Kingdom that's what we need
to resolve and I'm focused on getting a
solution and this when we get that
solution I am absolutely clear the dup
will be back in government doing our bit
to build a better future for everyone in
Northern Ireland every time unionism has
pulled out of government it has ended up
in a worse situation if there is no deal
to restore power sharing at the end of
all of this what is the alternative
surely we can't just be looking at a
return to direct rule from Westminster
after all these years I'm not prepared
to accept failure I'm going to work for
Success I'm going to work for a solution
and every single day I'm going to be at
Westminster or at storm or in Brussels
wherever I need to be to press for that
solution because we need that for
Northern Ireland we need stability we've
got got a cost of living crisis there
are many issues we need to be addressing
I want to see a fully functioning
devolved government again in Northern
Ireland so that's what I'm working
towards David I'm not prepared to accept
and that there won't be an outcome to
this
um I've often said before and I say it
again when I look at the last 25 years
in Northern Ireland the mountains we
have climbed to build peace and
stability are far higher than the
mountains in front of us but given that
unionism no longer holds sway to the
extent it once did is joint Authority
London and Dublin governing Northern
Ireland not a realistic possibility well
it is certainly not part of the Belfast
or Good Friday agreement the UK
government have made clear joint
Authority is not an option I think joint
Authority and even talk of joint
Authority David I think is reckless I
think it raises tension at a time when
what we all need to do is focus on
getting a solution and Joint Authority
is no solution
you very much
well that was the Democratic unionist
party leader Sir Jeffrey Donaldson
talking to David Blevins for this
program let's turn now to Champaign and
the party's vice president Michelle
O'Neill who would have become the first
Minister after the party topped the last
elections earlier this year thank you so
much for being on the program for us
today we just heard from Sir Jeffrey
saying that Northern Ireland doesn't
need an election what it needs is better
negotiations and sorting out the brexit
protocol do you think that there needs
to be an election
good morning Sophie well firstly we did
have an election we had an election back
in May last year and I think that
certainly my party you know the parties
were given a very strong mandate in
which to form a government actually to
support people during what is most one
of the most challenging time to think
that most people have been through in
terms of the cost of living crisis but
the outcome of that election is
continually being denied by the dup
um by Jeffrey Donaldson they failed to
accept the outcome of that election
their field to form a government and
they've failed to work with the rest of
us to get people through these teams so
you know we shouldn't have to have an
election
um because we have had one but
unfortunately that election result has
been disrespected now what we have at
this current moment in time is six
months post that election we have astero
Limbo with no government in place with
no ministers on post with nobody taken
decisions in the interests of the people
and it's just not acceptable it's just
not good enough
what's the difference between you know
the dep collapsing storm once over
something as fundamental as what they
see as the Constitutional question and
Chin Fame pulling it down for three
years over a botched green energy scheme
well it was a financial Scandal actually
the dup designed and delivered um it was
a scandal at what I saw the public
person for 500 million pounds I don't
think any government anywhere in the
world would have withstood such a
scandal but I also think that at that
time whenever it did collapse we worked
every day to try to put it back together
again but the dep ran over to London to
prop up the Tories and their forward
interested in actually establishment
government at home so I think that's
regrettable and not in that sense but
you know
I think where we are today is that the
public rightly deserve you know sensible
mature particular leaders working
together to try to form a government to
actually start to put money into their
pockets to get them through the course
live in crisis and unfortunately that is
not the case and we're caught up in the
midst of all of this mass chaos
dysfunction heartlessness if you like
observatories in London and the day you
pay you're on towards those people
instead of actually run towards the
people at home who actually want
politics to work you know I just think
that as we enter until next year which
will Mark 25 years of our peace process
25 years of our remarkable remarkable
Journey um or transformation in our
society and I think it's just such a
shame that we're sitting on a scenario
today in political Limbo with the public
are being denied access to democracy and
their votes but the do you appear Talent
paper right now their whole Stone count
the election that they voted for and
they voted in in May of this year is
being disrespected and I just don't
think that's good enough
you said that the the DP in your view
I'm sure that they would disagree are
not interested in forming a government
you know if you believe that do you
think it's partly because they are
uncomfortable with effectively power
sharing with you know Sinn Fein first
minister
yes I don't think it's lost on the way
to public I'd throw at the dep don't
like the male action results I don't
think it's lost in the way to Republic
that they have difficulty in forming a
government to be a deputy first minister
to my mandate which is to be the first
Minister uh given the recent election
result so I think it's not lost and
people that's actually the real
motivation here but the dep hide behind
the issues of the protocol they hide
behind all of that so what I want to say
in the time ahead is very mature
sensible political discussion between
both the British government and the EU
side let's find and agreed where to
solve the issues around the protocol and
I would make this case again disagree
with Jeffrey Lawson in the dup the
protocol is a necessity and it's here to
stay there are things that can be
smoothed out there are things that can
be made to work better and I'm up for
that and I hope that's what we achieve
in the common weeks and months there has
been a renewed Focus if you like between
both the British government and the EU
side to get uh to have discussions in
terms of making the protocol work and I
urge that to continue in Earnest and
actually to be ramped up and actually
find and agreed Way Forward because the
certain instability that will bring will
do two things it will provide that
certainly instability would allow us to
be able to look towards investment
opportunities per second to that then
it'll remove any pretense from the EP in
terms of forming an executive with
myself and with the rest of the parties
and the collapse institutions are you
know about the protocol but I think as
you probably acknowledge also about you
know a lack of trust across the Divide
in a recent interview you said this and
I don't think any Irish person ever woke
up one morning and thought that conflict
was a good idea but the war came to
Ireland I think at the time there was no
alternative but now thankfully we have
an alternative to conflict and that is a
good Friday agreement
and if I saying that there was no
alternative to you know the violence
that we've seen from the IRA during the
troubles are you not worried that you're
adding to some of that distrust you know
how will that persuade unionists that
you can be a first Minister for all
well the public had gave me a mandate to
be first Minister for all that I said
that I wanted to be but I think that you
have to realize that we have been a
society that has been absolutely
transformed over the course of the last
25 years in our precious peace process
has to be held on to with everything
we've got unfortunately this Tory
government care less for a peace process
and I think brexit um is a good case in
point you know brexit in the Good Friday
agreement we're never going to be
compatible but I think that you know
there's no doubt that we've had a very
um difficult past there's no doubt that
people have been hurt across the across
the pace across all over community and
all of my adult life has been about
building the peace but if I want to
truly reconcile our people if we're
going to truly look towards the future
and if we're going to unburden today's
young people of the past then we need to
properly deal with the class not as they
acknowledge that there are different
narratives of the past people have very
different lived experiences and we have
to most importantly ensure that those
conditions never ever exist again so for
me this is about looking towards the
future as opposed to looking towards the
past but we have to absolutely we deal
with the past and the approach of the
story government to for example bring
forward this bill in terms of dealing
with the past is absolutely shameful and
symbolic and it is not an there's no
clinical support for the legislation
that they're bringing through
Westminster in terms of an amnesty
there's no clinical support from any
political reporter from any of the
victims and Survivor scripts so how are
we going to look towards the future if
we don't properly inadequate it with the
past
and you're talking about the uh Tory
government so I am interested to finally
just get your view on which is sunak the
new prime minister also of course we've
seen Chris Heaton Harris reappointed as
a Northern Ireland secretary do you
welcome those two appointments or do you
have any concerns
I'm so fairly look forward to today
whenever there isn't any interference in
terms of the British government in terms
of the Irish people's Affairs here and
however this is the scenario that we
find ourselves in today but there's no
doubt that these the Tory party don't
care less for the Good Friday agreement
they certainly don't care for the people
they're not acting in the interests of
anybody the past three months has been
about self-serve an agenda about Stanton
Park
um and I think that the policy decisions
of the Tories
um really make people's lives much much
more difficult every day and the events
of recent weeks and months have
demonstrated that
um but for now the the British
government are a coal guarantor of our
peace agreement and my interest is is
the interest of the people here so I
will work with them I encourage
um the new British prime minister to
continue to work with the EU to ramp up
those discussions find ways to smooth
out the protocol make it work and get a
better done and bring that certain
instability that the people here deserve
okay thank you very much indeed Michelle
O'Neill then
now the war in Ukraine is entering yet
another Grim phase as a cold winter
approaches Russia has now deployed tens
of thousands of reservists but Ukraine
continues to push to retake ground
especially in the South meanwhile Russia
has suspended a deal that allows the
export of grain following attacks on its
Fleet
well we can talk now to the Ukrainian MP
in a subson who joins us now live from
Keith thank you so much for being on the
program you know particularly from where
you're coming from in Kiev we're very
grateful to have you
now a couple of minutes ago a couple of
weeks ago Keith was targeted by Russian
missiles for the first time in months
what was that like for you and your
family
well the first day of the attack I was
about to take my son to school and and
uh that didn't work out too well so we
actually ended up in the underground
station for three and a half hours with
the thousands of private people who were
trying to find a shelter over there then
the attacks continued on the next couple
of days up to this week and uh I think
people have calmed down a little bit
about it so yeah people are still trying
to find shelter but there were not big
hits after that in the city the major
change that did affect the lives of the
civilian population was of course that
the energy infrastructure was hit very
badly and we were having a blackouts
from time to time but yesterday was
actually the first day when I didn't
have my when I had electricity during
the whole day at my home so I think some
things got fixed and uh yeah so it's uh
it's better to an extent possible
uh yeah and certainly I can imagine that
it must be just the uncertainty of where
you are and going through something
where you live in Keith with your son
must have been very difficult uh indeed
um you I believe after the bombing you
and your son went to the metro station
to shelter and what was it like how did
how did you find it
well uh it was not uh very easy because
my son is 10 and and at some point when
we Gathering our staff at home and I was
telling him that we're going to the
underground station he looked at me and
he said Mom am I going to die and I had
to be very calm and to say no I'm I'm
doing my best to protect you but trust
me this is not the question you want to
be answering to your kids at any point
of time and then when we were rushing to
the metro station uh he looked at me
again and said mom is that those bombs
that we're hearing are those the nuclear
pumps or the regular ones and I said
well those are the regular ones why are
you ask him and he looked at me rather
proudly and he said because I know what
to do in case of the nuclear attack
because that is what we learned at
school and that is again something you
never want to hear from from your child
um but he was rather calm and he's like
yeah we had instructions about what to
do so I will tell you what to do in case
you forgot
uh again not a conversation you want to
be having but um part of our daily life
here but inside the metro station uh
people will actually rather calm people
knew what to do people got their stuff
they got something to sit on they got
water they got medicines and all of that
yeah exactly what you are seeing right
now I think that's actually video from
from my Twitter uh you can see that
people were yeah radical and I would
hear people calling their relatives
their loved ones saying yeah we are fine
as soon as this is over we'll go back to
to work nobody was saying that we have
to flee we have to run away we have to
get away from Ukraine and so on and so
forth and actually the amazing thing is
that according to our Buddha agency they
said that actually the number of people
who left the country in the last couple
of weeks after those attacks on big
series uh started has actually decreased
so people are not running away
well I have to say your son sounds
pretty incredible in that situation to
be saying don't worry I know what to do
if there's a nuclear bomb uh that
resilience
um absolutely extraordinary stuff
and your boyfriend I think is fighting
uh with the Ukrainian forces if you
managed to stay in touch with him
uh we do uh to an extent possible uh
sometimes it just you know sending a
text to him and asking if he's okay and
he says I'm okay which is good enough
for me uh he's actually in cave today
for for one day so uh that's uh that's
great
um but it's the first time in three
months I guess other than that he spends
most of his time over there in the
Battlefront he's a military medic so
he's helping people right there on the
battlefield
um thank you for doing this interview if
your boyfriend is in Kiev today uh after
fighting you know on the front line and
makes us even more grateful that you're
giving up the time to to talk to us and
given that let's try and get your
message out there as much as possible
um the UK's new prime minister had a
call with President zielinski this week
are you confident that Rishi sunak will
be as great an ally as Boris Johnson was
but actually one of the reasons I
continued doing this despite Sasha my
boyfriend being here in Kiev is because
my job is so well he is fighting on the
Battlefront my job is to continue
fighting on the Diplomatic front as a
member of parliament so that is what I'm
continuing to do and of course Britain
is is a crucially important partner for
all of us we have been extremely
grateful for the support we have
received from the United Kingdom and we
do hope that it will continue and the
fact that the new prime minister already
talked to our president is reassuring so
we do hope that the situation internal
situation in the UK will stabilize and
that support will actually continue
we're very much wait for for uh Mr sonak
to come over here to keep
a bit of a fun stuff around here there
is a famous bakery in Kiev which has
made a bakery thingy which was called
Boris Johnson because we were so much a
fan of the previous prime minister and
they have already made a new one called
racism so he really should come because
he's very much awaited here in Kiev and
we very much hope that this support will
continue and will actually grow because
there are still some things that we are
not getting from our Western Partners
particularly the tanks and that is
something that we need to be talking
about because that is what our military
guys on the Battleground need very much
and we hope that the new prime minister
will be pushing about as well
I'm talking about the international
response it feels like there may be some
cracks forming in what has been up till
now quite a United response from the
United States with some calling on
President Biden to push harder for peace
talks are you concerned about the US
I am a bit concerned I'm actually
traveling to to the us at the end of
this week and I do hope to understand
the internal situation a bit better of
course we are a bit concerned about the
elections coming up in the United States
we do hope they will not change the the
willingness of the current
Administration to help Ukraine but yeah
we are concerned and we do hope that
after all what will be clear to the you
know to the politicians in in the CEO in
London uh is that we are working
together because of our shared interest
and our shared interest is to contain
authoritarianism uh in in you know in
the in the world so those shared
interests do not change because of the
Electoral results and hope that will be
you know clear to everyone else
I thank you so much for being with us
today talking about you know your own
experiences and what the West needs to
do and also I do really hope that you
get to spend a bit of time with your
boyfriend today as well so um thank you
thank you so much
they're always absolutely extraordinary
uh the interviews coming out of Ukraine
we're definitely going to commit to keep
doing them on this program
uh well we can return now to leveling up
earlier of course in the program Michael
Gove said that there has been progress
but there is much more to do now
Bradford is often held up as a prime
example of somewhere that could benefit
from leveling up that of course it
remains one of the most deprived places
in the country with quite poor transport
links in particular well Bradford city
council leader Susan Hinchcliffe joins
us now thank you very much for being uh
with us
um are you pleased to see Michael go
back in his job as leveling up secretary
so generally I think it runs the Mayors
and local Authority leaders we're
pleased to see somebody who's got a bit
of clout a bit of government experience
who wants to get things done because
that's what we really need we need to do
leveling up not just to be the domain of
one government department they need to
be able to live influence the Department
of Transport Department of Health and of
course importantly the treasury to May
Builders to get things done and to grow
our economy locally
now Bradford is the 13th most deprived
local Authority in the whole of England
so obviously a prime candidate for
leveling up
they've had three years they're the
conservatives and since the 2019
election when they were elected on the
Mandate for leveling up how's it gone so
far
so obviously like the rest of the nation
uh Bradford is struggling in terms of
rising costs of inflation uh as um
budgetary guidelines with 45 million uh
as gappy this year 33 million of that is
inflation and that's in common with a
lot of the local authorities around the
country we really do need that Gap
funding because otherwise we won't be
able to develop and grow our economies
so so far obviously like the rest of the
nation it's been a very bumpy ride but
we're we believe in our place we're the
youngest City in the UK here 140 000
children in school we're going to be a
city of culture in 2025. we're investing
here and I need a government that also
believes in investing alongside us
because we need that station as you say
we've got poor transport links we need
to be connected to the mainline Railway
and make sure we can get to Manchester
more easily as well as Lee's and that
requires an investment by government for
a new station but it's something that
all the northern leaders agree on and
actually transport select committee
agree on so let's get that done so it's
things like that that we need a really
more proactive conversation with
government about we're hoping Mackle
Grove can help us open doors
let's talk let's talk a bit about
transport shall we because obviously the
city does have a particular issue when
it comes to transport now Liz Tross said
that she would build Northern Powerhouse
rail in full including that crucial
station in Bradford reversing a decision
to scrap it that was taken by the
previous administration which of course
Michael gave was a part of are you
worried that given the cost pressure as
this government is now facing they might
go back on the list trust plan
I don't think they can afford to go back
on it to be quite honest if we're really
serious about growing our economy we
have to invest in our transport and our
skills in our culture actually as well
which is a city of culture is important
for us but if you don't invest in your
human capital pause brexit we are not
actually going to succeed as a nation so
it's really important to invest in young
people get them into colleges get them
into good jobs so they can create a good
income for themselves and their family
going forward we cannot afford levels of
poverty in this country that has been
seen and you know at the moment one in
five pounds from government is spent on
alleviating poverty we need to spend it
more wisely to make sure we get up front
of that and actually invest in growth
and make sure people have a good income
going forward so I believe in what we've
got here as a plan we know the station
will create another 27 000 more jobs it
will create another three billion gva
over a 10-year period why would any
government say no to that whoever is in
charge and that's the case we're making
strongly and that we see others are also
coming along side you say you want to
invest in growth I mean that's what Liz
trust tried to do isn't it didn't go so
great for her
no absolutely and obviously we don't
deal with taxation to that level of
local government for us it's about
investing in things like one city park
like the new markets we're doing like
Bradford live four thousand seats a live
music venue but to be able to do that we
do need to be able to fund the people
who deliver those projects for us so
coming forward to the next financial
statements that the treasury is going to
make we need to see that they're going
to funnel local authorities to keep
delivering because we're delivering
growth at local level we are the arms of
government who can actually deliver that
growth and if we're not funded to do so
all we do is spend all our time trying
to cut back services and that's not good
for the public we serve or for the
ambitious growth that the government
says they've got we want to be part of a
growth plan and we think we can help
deliver that
there's a study done by Bloomberg in
June this year where they looked at how
leveling up was going and they said that
you know public spending is actually
increasing in constituencies around
London and actually in the rest of the
UK so in the north of England it's
actually uh falling back uh compared to
2019 levels the ippr think tank as well
says that between 2010 and 2020 just 349
pounds was spent per person on transport
in the north
864 pounds per person in London do you
think that there is I guess a bias in
Westminster against places outside
London
yeah I mean you mentioned earlier in the
program about Richardson in his
um what he said in sunbridge Wells and
that was heartbreaking to hear that
actually because I do think the
government should be really honest about
the leveling up agenda and mean it
because it's the right intent we all
believe it's in the right intent and
they therefore need to make sure that
their money you know backs that intent
and obviously we think that the north
has a lot to offer if you actually get
all the citizens of the north together
we work together as one we know that
combined our economies can really
accelerate and and get rid of some of
that deficit that obviously government
is really grappling with so it's about
having a long-term plan if you only
invest in Urgent Care in hospitals for
example you're never going to get ahead
of that curve you're never going to
invest in making sure people are
long-term healthy lives with good jobs
that keep them well and that's what
we're in at the moment as a country we
need to make sure we get ahead of the
Urgent Care the urgent need in this
country so that people are able to be
equipped to lead healthy wealthy lives
and can feed them their children and
have a good successful life which keeps
them out of that urgent care whether
it's in hospitals or any other public
services it's really we need a long-term
Vision we have that in Bradford and
obviously I'm happy to talk to
government about how we're going to work
that in the north and of course in the
rest of the country as Bradford's power
but we do need to think long term
because this is a long-term ambition for
all of us now I want to talk to you to
end about children in Bradford because
child poverty and Bradford is the
highest in Yorkshire figures from and
child poverty show 50 of people children
in Bradford East 51 in Bradford West 42
in Bradford South are in poverty now
given that backdrop your councils
children's services would deemed to be
inadequate so bad about the education
secretary had to step in and take it
away from the council
did you consider resigning over that
we answered questions at the time around
that and obviously we take child safety
and child safeguarding very seriously
we're pleased to be working with
government to create a new children's
trust who just appointed a chair and a
chief executive who have got fantastic
experience of turning things around
we're working really hard with them
because we know that as a younger City
our children deserve the best and we do
believe that we've now got good people
in place who can take it Forward go
forward and we will work with them
absolutely to make sure it's success
there is nothing more important than
getting things right for our children as
I said we're the youngest city that has
to happen to take responsibility for
what happened
absolutely and I said that at the time
and made obviously apologies on that
regard as well
um that is something that obviously
stays with us that we'll never forget uh
and that we need to make sure we put
right for the future of our children and
of our prosperity of our districts those
young people growing up here today need
to be the wealth creators of the future
and with Rising child neglect and
poverty that is going to be an issue
across the country to make sure that
children stay with their families and
Lead healthy wealthy lives but we have a
big part to play in that with the trust
going forward and we want to create
Bradford to be the best place in the
country for children to grow up okay
thank you very much indeed great to talk
to you about leveling up from Bradford
looking very beautiful behind you I have
to say
thank you
well that is it for this week's safer
Ridge on Sunday in a moment after the
break we're going to be running through
today is their interviews with our
Deputy political editors Sam coats plus
do check out the podcast that should be
available around lunchtime with myself
Scott Beasley my producer and Liz Bates
are political correspondent thanks for
joining us this Sunday morning
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the take where we take you back through
the morning's interviews and we have
some analysis for you for myself and our
Deputy political editor at some coats
too well it's been another remarkable
week I can't even believe it's all been
in this week to be honest you know
another change of prime minister another
cabinet reshuffle but of course the
country's still facing a raft of
difficult economic issues that I'm sure
are going to really color all of our
political debates over the next few
months well we're joined by adaptive
physical editor Sam coats good to have
you with us Sam complete with your
screen as well
um Michael Gove this morning I thought
he was a pretty upfront actually about a
lot of things it was quite a one of
those interviews where you know he
didn't really hold back he started off
by apologizing for installing Liz truss
as prime minister
that's right isn't it fascinating Sophie
actually I suspect that we are going to
hear
disproportionately about Liz truss's 49
days in power now this government might
say it wants to move on but it also
wants essentially to try and blame Liz
trust for absolutely every problem uh
that they're now trying to fix probably
mostly uh fairly some of which I suspect
might raise some eyebrows so whether
it's the spending cups to come some of
the challenges around different bits of
the state even when it comes to Northern
land I think that there is just a sense
that they want to communicate that
they're mopping up Liz trusses messes
that's what Richie sunac did when he
stood on the steps of Downing Street on
Tuesday is very much the tone of Michael
Gove and in a funny way Sophie it also
strikes me that's the goal of the
opposition as well that there is just a
little bit of nervousness in inside the
labor party that Rishi sunak will come
across to the public as more sensible as
more competent and somebody they can
trust more so they too are trying to
talk up those 49 turbulent days of Liz
trust as a political tactic so I don't
think apologizing might by Michael Gove
was a mistake at all I think it's a
large part of this new government's
political tactic
have a quick listen to Michael gave at
shall we before we go back to Sam and we
talked to the leveling up secretary
about that resignation let's have a
listen to what he said
I think we made a mistake we took the
wrong turn uh the mini budget as I think
everyone now recognizes contained a a
number of false steps I think it was
wrong to cut taxes for the wealthiest
and it was also wrong to proceed with
tax cuts without saying how they were
going to be paid for
um and to be fair Jeremy Hunters
Chancellor as soon as he was installed
made clear that those mistakes would
have to be addressed and Rishi sunak as
prime minister of course has been
Vindicated to some of the judgments that
he made during the course of the summer
during the course of the leadership
election have been shown to be correct
and Rishi now along with Jeremy and the
rest of us in government have some
difficult decisions to take but what we
must do is be honest with the British
people in order to regain Trust
and Michael Gove there Sam I was quite
interested when you were talking about
how actually it's kind of in Rishi
sooner and his new cabinet's interest to
blame everything on Liz truss because
that's quite difficult to do
particularly when it comes to leveling
up right you know they've had since 2019
so they've had three years to try and
level up you know when I was researching
the interview for Michael go there's an
awful lot of evidence that actually
things have got worse rather than better
if you look at the Bloomberg study if
you look at the ippr uh research then
actually particularly in those
constituencies around England and the
north of England and those areas outside
London
things have been leveling down if
anything
absolutely I I think this tactic will
work for a little bit I mean the last 49
days of Liz trust were just an
extraordinary roller coaster of
turbulence
um but in the end I think if the sunat
government relied too much on pointing
to Liz truss's problems then after a
while the public will go come on you're
elected as a conservative government
under Boris Johnson in 2019 what about
all the promises that you made uh then
but but nevertheless they will try very
interesting that as it were the news
announcement I thought the biggest news
announcement this morning was Michael
Gove saying well giving a pretty big
hint that investment zones are so
conceived by Liz truss and quasiquarting
and Simon Clark the previous trop Trio
they effectively very likely to be
junked now those investment zones are
areas where there could be low taxes
lower regulation in order to Spur growth
in particular parts of the country
Michael Gove said look I'm not
particularly keen on them because I
don't think that they're a sufficient
environment protections you could be
concreting over protected land you could
be harming the environment in these
zones so I'm not terribly Keen so we're
reviewing them and it didn't pretty much
sound like they were going to end up the
other side of the Sausage Factory
looking very much like they did at the
moment so that's one way that they can
try and provide a fire break blame
something in the leveling and Drop It Up
agenda on Liz trust but you're right
when you look at all the metrics all the
problems they were there and discussed
during the leadership contest and
therefore not there really during uh not
just caused by Liz truss's time in power
but but you look across the piste and
there are issues and I think this is I
think in a moment what we're going to
listen to next there are issues a bit
like the bigger leveling up problems and
the investment challenges and uh the
scenes on the high streets and crime
there are issues where ministers just
can't escape some kind of broader mayor
culpr and that's why the language from
Michael gave cautious uh language around
brexit was so fascinating this morning
uh desperately trying to balance the
positive with the negative but just to
hear one of the two main architects of
the brexit referendum in 2016 talking
the way that he did to you I thought was
was quite striking previously no element
of brexit tended to be recognized as a
as a problem but you know what he said
to you this morning suggested that their
this government at least is moving to a
slightly different approach let's have a
listen to that shall we
I think it's important to look at a big
question like brexit and to recognize
that you can't make a snap judgment a
few years later and say definitively
that everything as a result of uh
leaving the European Union has gone
precisely in a perfect way I think on
balance brexit has been a significant
success for this country but I do
acknowledge that there have been
frictions and my friend uh Steve Baker
for example acknowledged that as we
resolve the situation in Northern
Ireland but some of the things that have
been said and done haven't necessarily
been perfectly pitched I think that is
an example of something that we need to
address but overall I think we wouldn't
have had the vaccine rollout that was so
successful if we'd been within the
European Union and in an area for which
I was previously responsible in the
environment we wouldn't have a better
method of supporting Farmers that
strengthens the environment as well as
enhancing food production if we were in
the common agricultural policy
uh Michael gave there talking about
brexit and Sam it's right I was kind of
fascinated by that uh interview as well
and what he said it came from a
financial times interview that he did uh
over in September I think so before he
entered the a cabinet where again he was
quite he was just quite fascinating he's
obviously wrestling still or thinking
back still about brexit was it as he
expected um you know had there been
things that have gone wrong and so
that's why I really wanted to pose some
of those rhetorical questions that he
was asking to himself and I think we did
get a bit of an Insight of of course he
was very keen to say that on balance he
thinks it's the right thing but there
was a hint of that reflection
absolutely and Michael grave is usually
slightly less reflective in government
than he is uh in those brief periods
that he's had in the last 11 years out
of the cabinet and I also think you've
just got that little sense of the real
Michael Gove I hate to say this Sophie
but I I think I get the impression at
times that Michael good can be an
incredibly tortured individual he does
grapple uh with difficult questions
properly Dark Knights of the soul I
think there is a sort of sense to him
that he really thinks very deeply about
stuff and and it's quite a journey for
him uh making all the big decisions that
he's made through his uh political
career and occasionally like on the
interview with you just now you've got a
sense of that but he touched on the fact
that of course brexit
still has a relevance in day-to-day
political life when it comes to Northern
Ireland and again this morning that's
another big problem for this government
the government looks looks as if it's
about to call an election in Northern
Ireland I don't think we've quite had a
date yet which has raised some eyebrows
amongst the Northern Ireland uh parties
but you heard from all sides of the
spectrum on your on your show and
essentially you have the unionists who
are the most worried about the situation
effectively going don't call an election
try and sort out or scrap the protocol
but it looks as if Rishi sunak may break
with the approach of Boris Johnson and
the apparent approach of Liz truss and
actually try and prioritize some kind of
negotiation with the EU over the kind of
uh more bombastic more aggressive
approach that they've had and and that
and I think you could see in Rishi
sinat's first week with his
conversations with world leaders and the
read actor quite positive readouts you
were getting from the French President
and others uh that that tone is going
down quite well which will be necessary
to solve I think one of the other
biggest problems which was to do with
small boats and the people traffickers
taking uh people across the channel to
the UK now that is understandably an
issue uh particularly with the latest
Revelations to do with the manston
center uh that's quite live at the
moment but in the end this is all part
and parcel of the same question whether
or not a combative robust approach for
instance to the French government will
help help on this issue and whether or
not a slightly softer tone might help
and that's where swella braveman the
Home Secretary is caught in a storm that
labor really wants to highlight thanks
very much uh Sam we'll have more from
you after the break in a short moment
we're going to be reflecting about Rishi
sunx first week as prime minister but I
think certainly it's interesting because
it feels to me like this is a week on
the show we've been talking about policy
and that hasn't really happened for a
while because of the crazy roller
coaster we've been on uh with politics
so certainly it's been quite nice to
kind of take a pause and talk a bit more
about policy at a time of course of such
critical juncture for the United Kingdom
more coming out in just a few moments
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few years have seen
have huge stories
foreign
s have been driven by politics by
politicians the people in power you must
stay at home and it's my job to figure
out how these decisions made by
politicians impact all of us in our
everyday lives this is the worst thing
I've ever been through in my life people
turn up here with their child's stuff in
a black sack and just say I don't want
to and that is what it is it's first
class poverty is this an example of the
welfare state failing we take you to the
heart of the stories that shape our
world these are stories that affect us
all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Sunday the take we've been taking back
through some of the mornings interviews
mainly the Michael Gove won the new
leveling up secretary but now at time
perhaps to reflect on which you see next
first week as prime minister we can
bring Sam back in and have a little chat
with him about what it's been uh like
um it feels like in a way you know
there's been so much build up williamty
is he gonna win like it doesn't feel
like a surprise to see what she's seen
that as a prime minister in a way
um have we learned anything new about
him do you think in the last uh you know
five days
I mean I think he's in an incredibly
difficult situation this is the job he
fought for over the summer he didn't win
the leadership contest the conservative
party remained incredibly fractured
there is now an economic crisis laid
upon the uh political crisis LED upon
the uh International crisis with the war
in Ukraine and I think that he now steps
into Downing Street in a completely
unenviable situation but so if you look
at this that this is the picture of the
new modern British State a new king
barely weeps in the job and they're
Britain's first Asian prime minister and
and that was something really celebrated
and it's remarkable it was celebrated
around the world whether it was
President Joe Biden uh who talked about
its Global significance earlier this
week whether it was Narendra Modi who
clearly had a very warm uh phone call
with Rishi sunak this week's perhaps
suggesting a bit more of a reset because
there was some uh upset around um
amongst Indians about uh Liz truss's um
plans on visas uh and the trade deals so
a reset with India um but just as an
image of where we are compared to where
we were I think it's I think it's quite
striking and I think all of that just
means that politics once again thrown up
in the air and we just don't yet know
where the where all the cards are gonna
land
uh yeah it was incredible uh that image
wasn't it one of several images I guess
that I kind of feel have you know
defined uh this week uh in uh many ways
that one I love that one that you're
showing there of the new cabinet I mean
I say new cabinet it was quite a lot of
familiar faces around that table uh
weren't there I guess they're kind of
refreshed and Back Back to the Future
cabinet
absolutely I mean you can kind of have a
look you know uh resigned uh forced to
resign uh once resigned uh did resign
and I can go on all the way uh along uh
many of whom lost their jobs during uh
Boris Johnson's time uh for one reason
or another so these are not uh new faces
to our viewers even if they're new faces
uh some of them around the cabinet table
what what I thought about Rishi sunat's
cabinet appointment was whilst he came
in and the stove the tone of a lot of
his opening remarks reflected strength
and Contrition I thought that the actual
cabinet appointments were a little bit
more defensive because what he's doing
is he's trying to balance the different
factions around the cabinet table so I
mean that's I think where why soilla
Braverman is so important she's sitting
opposite the Prime Minister here she
represents the hard brexite as a wing
that he clearly doesn't want to upset
you've got people who've been Perpetual
critics of Richardson like Andrew
Mitchell who has complained about the
decision to cut Aid uh prices but then
you've got reward for some of the people
who are quite controversially involved
in the ousting of Boris Johnson their
smiling Mark Harper he was one of the
figures most robustly involved in the
defenestration uh of um of uh of Boris
Johnson sitting opposite Nadim sahawi
who for a two-hour period uh last
weekend which is a lifetime ago back to
return of Boris Johnson saying Boris 2.0
was right for the country and then
quickly smelt the way that the wind was
blowing and changed his mind so a a a a
a new old new cabinet for Rishi sunak
reflecting the tensions inside the
conservative party in the fact that
however much Tory MPS might want to tell
you uh that everything has changed
actually this is a party that's gone
through so much along with the country
since 20 the 2019 December 2019 election
and it really is uh I guess put into the
test at that old adage that it's better
to have people inside the tent I mean
with that lot around inside the tent I
think it would be really interesting to
see whether or not that plays out at all
another defining image from the week
there Rishi sunak at Diwali I think
that's one of my favorite photos of the
week
yes and as the first Hindu in Downing
Street there you see him at the Diwali
celebration I believe that's in Downing
Street I believe that was uh on
Wednesday uh just before your nine
o'clock show this week and this is just
not something that we've seen uh before
um arguably one of the most passionate
people of faith that we've had in
Downing Street in some time David
Cameron might have talked about his
faith going in and out of the uh a
little bit like the radio signal in the
chiltons but I think nobody doubts the
sincerity of Rishi sunak when it comes
to uh comes to his faith and I think
that that just provides a sort of
CounterPoint uh to a lot of what we've
said is it's an interesting different
approach
um in a country where demonic is the
defender of the Church of England so uh
interesting uh it's just an interesting
new development in in the way that our
State wins but then some old challenges
as well this uh was Friday
um you had Richie sunac down uh at a
hospital visit uh in the south of
England and he was accosted by a patient
making in this exchange made many of the
front pages and I think this is the kind
of Politics as normal that we that we
might be back to
um but it's the NHS I think that he
recognizes he signaled that he
recognizes uh has uh he's gonna really
uh dominate quite a lot of people's uh
views about his government at a time
where yes they might be able to keep the
kind of the the ring fence in other
words uh but keep their commitment that
the NHS budget should grow uh but with
all of the inflationary pressures but
the fact that everything including for
the NHS for doctors and nurses and NHS
managers costs a lot more the NHS will
have to do more with less and that's
potentially going to result in more
exchanges like this one so so that's
what kind of Politics as normal looks
like that's that's that you know none of
this ahead of the spending statement in
about what is it uh two and a half three
weeks time uh is is going to be made
easier uh none of this is going to be
made easier by the hugely difficult
decisions and the 50 billion pounds of
cuts that his government and this man is
going to have to make yeah that really
is the Big Challenge isn't it for Rishi
cnx her Premiership the defining
challenge uh Sam thanks for talking to
those images it's lovely to see them I
just want to finish by having a little
listen to a bit of the end of my Michael
guide interview because I think this
actually did give us a bit of an insight
into Rishi CNAC as well because Michael
Gove has been there for many many
different uh pmqs prep for different
leaders David Cameron Boris Johnson most
recently Rishi sunak so I thought he
might have a bit of insight into you
know how Rishi sunak prepares for those
moments of Maximum stress
I know that when Boris was a prime
minister uh he liked to have uh one of
the the team in number 10 play kyostarma
um and so there were two particular uh
aides who at different times played
kirst armor um Richie likes to look at
it issue by issue by issue in a very
methodical way does someone play Kirsten
with furicio Scenic as well
um there is one incredibly bright person
who ran through the questions that kirst
armor might um uh might run um I will
spare the blushes of that person uh
simply to say that she's one of the
smartest people I've ever worked with
okay uh very interesting to know that
you've had a bit of ever come back as
well haven't you were you expecting uh
to be back in cabinet no does this mean
we're going to be seeing a bit less of
you in the nightclubs yes
I love those direct answers from Michael
Gove the yes or no they're my favorites
I think
Sam
uh yeah he is one of the most colorful
figures in cabinet but colorful isn't
actually what this government wants to
do they want to do boring and sensible
they pulled all their uh business for
this week to try and calm things down
but given the challenges will wishes you
not succeed yeah that is the big
question Sam thank you very much indeed
a serious government from Russia Sino
that's what he wants to project and I
think that's why perhaps we might be
seeing a few more appearances by people
like Michael Gove people they see as
serious big hitters on programs like
this one that is it from safety Ridge on
Sunday the take have a lovely rest of
your weekend and do remember check out
the podcast that should be available
around lunchtime wherever you normally
get your podcast we're going to be
digesting at some of those interviews
and trying to work out what we learned
see you next Sunday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]